on n'a pas été assez audacieux on a bien
vu que cette gestion de la crise
sanitaire elle s'est fait d'une façon
sûre administré avec des deux principes
de précaution multiplier à tous les
étages tropez sur la question des
réactions trop il ya des choses qui sont
mises en place dans les pays étrangers
depuis fort longtemps
je pense aux auto test moi j'étais au
royaume uni à noël à noël aux pratiques
et les autotests et ça se passait très
bien
aujourd'hui on n'est toujours pas en
capacité de mettre à disposition des
français des autotests des tests
salivaires au motif qu' il ne serait pas
certain à 100%
voilà cet excès de prudence et cet
esprit trop précautionneux qui nous
empêche d'aller loin moi je dirais pas
manque de folie on n'a pas besoin de
folie de la part de nos dirigeants
on a besoin d'audace on a besoin du
résultat on a besoin de l'islamo
gauchisme à l'université qui est en
train de compromettre gravement la
liberté académique et les savoirs
académiques à on voit bien que les
indigéniste les essentialiste et
racialiste qui développe des théories
victimaire qui sont extrêmement
dangereuses je rappelle que l'université
c'est quand même la matrice de la
formation des enseignants d'autres pays
donc c'est l'enjeu et qu'on est
complètement considérable la réponse du
gouvernement est d'une faiblesse absolue
parce que la condamnation verbale ne
suffit pas il faut prendre des mesures
c'est quoi les mesures caballé mesure
dans le moi je considère que
une syndicat étudiant qui prône des
stages interdit aux blancs fait preuve
d'un racisme qu'il faut qu'on ait des
leads cette affaire doit aller en
justice il ya du racisme caractérisé il
faut lutter pied à pied contre l'islamo
gauchisme dans l'université et pas se
contenter de le dénoncer verbalement
comme ça ça veut dire clairement vous
demander au gouvernement de porter
plainte contre l'unef travers par
exemple a par exemple certains même
prône la dissolution ont dissous
génération identitaire
ça pose la question de savoir s'il faut
dissoudre l'unef
et puis que la ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur prennent des
mesures pour soutenir les courageux
professeur qui risque gros
lorsqu'il dénonce ces mouvements on l'a
vu à grenay là elle a été l'une des
premières à mettre le sujet sera tort
elle a été courageuse de le dire mais ça
suffit pas depuis qu'elle l'a dit elle
est très prudente parce qu'elle s'est
fait énormément attaquer il faut
maintenant que le gouvernement soit
derrière elle pour prendre des mesures
offensives c'est un sujet et un enjeu